Senate Republicans are scrambling to
save their tax bill after it hit a
stumbling block over deficit concerns
the legislation appeared to gain
momentum yesterday when it picked up
crucial GOP support but a study showing
the massive tax cut would add a trillion
dollars to the annual deficit brought it
to a screeching halt a handful of
Republican deficit hawks are hesitant to
support the bill Senate aides delivered
pizza as lawmakers debated into the
night they go back to work this morning
and Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
the new timing for the tax overhaul
Nancy good morning good morning well
Republican leaders are hoping to hold a
final vote today but they are still
making changes to win over the holdouts
arizona's john mccain is now a yes but
others want tweaks after independant
number crunchers found that the tax plan
won't pay for itself as promised
economic consulting has been as bad as
accurate as late-night psychic hotlines
most Republicans shook off the findings
of the bipartisan Joint Committee on
taxation which is projecting that
economic growth from the GOP tax plan
would only cover about four hundred
billion dollars worth of the one point
four trillion dollar cost
I think the jcj scoring is highly
questionable but a few GOP deficit hawks
like Tennessee's bob corker began
looking for ways to cut the bill's price
tag one idea to scale back the bills
generous 15-point corporate tax cut
protesters rallied against the bill
while the Senate debated it inside
Democrats argued the plans cost isn't
the only problem it will enrich the very
wealthiest Americans it will temporarily
help the middle class but the
middle-class tax cuts expire but many
Republicans say it's better to move
ahead with an imperfect plan than wait
and lose momentum
I just can't fail
this is just unacceptable for the
Republican Party that the House the
Senate and the White House and not via
the reform to the tax code that's just
unacceptable Blanca he and other
Republicans argue they can still make
changes to the plan after it passes when
Senate Republicans and House Republicans
work to meld their two very different
bills a process that the president wants
wrapped up plaid by Christmas Nancy
Cordes thank you very much